what are three mistakes screenwriters
make with loglines
well the three that i tend to see are
um stopping at the setup so
describing just the you know the initial
situation
and not really giving us any indication
of what happens in the the meat of the
movie
if that makes sense um so
you know often when we come at stories
we
we come with an interesting what if and
that's a great you know entry point into
a story but then
you sort of have to develop that that
continuation of
of the conflict right like what's the
real problem that they're trying to
solve
um in a log line if you just give me the
setup i don't know if you've thought
that through if you've
come up with the story part of your of
your screenplay i know that you've come
up with a situation but not necessarily
a story so
that's the first mistake that i see
people make with log lines
um the second one is um
is not having an act two which is a
little bit different than the first one
uh if you are conveying to me what's
happening in your movie but it's
something
sort of transitory or that can be done
in you know one scene
or one minute then that raises a little
bit of a red flag because
then it feels like maybe you don't have
enough to sustain an entire movie
um and then the third mistake that i see
a lot is
packing too much detail into your
logline so you know
usually this happens after somebody has
written the script and so they know
so much about the story and they've
fallen in love with everything that
they've written
that then they try to write they try to
distill all of that down into one
sentence and it's really hard because
they have all these details that they
know and all these you know subplots and
supporting characters and character arcs
and all these
all this stuff and so um they'll try to
jam all of that into one sentence and
then that just makes it
confusing and we want that log line to
ultimately to just really convey a solid
sense of
what that movie is that we'll be
watching if we sit down in the theater
right
so we need to know like what's that main
conflict that big conflict that we're
going to be
tracking over the course of that movie
and have a sense of the the nature of
the action that we're watching on screen
so what are what are the you know sort
of broad strokes things that that
character is doing
in pursuit of that story goal um that's
really what you're trying to get
into the log line and like i will say
you can start with those sort of
four foundational elements your
protagonist the story goal
the antagonist or main force of
opposition and the stakes
start there write one sentence with
those elements
and that should give you a really good
start for your log line you may need to
add a few details but
that way you're starting with a solid
foundation and then you can
add details as necessary rather than you
know starting
by putting everything you know about the
story into a sentence and then trying to
pull things out
so going back to uh the log line example
that we did and i don't know
whether this video will come out before
the other one so um
people might be confused by what i'm
referring to but
the log line that i gave you was
definitely confusing and there was too
much
in it so we cleaned it up and we found
out that it wasn't just about the
writing group it was more about her
finding love
yeah so that was getting to the meat of
it yeah because
i think if you were gonna if you were
going to write that script it sounded
like what
the story that you wanted to tell was
really about this mismatched romance
right
and so that's what we want to convey in
the log line because then when i read
the script or i watch the movie
that's the movie that i'm getting you're
not you're not telling me um
that uh dangerous minds story you know
you're telling me the the english
patient or whatever and so
those are you know both both movies that
work but
but i want to know which one i'm getting
before i pick up that script or
before i go see that movie so making
sure that you convey a
true sense of the story that you want to
tell in that log line that's
you know that's what we're looking for
what situation
will a screenwriter use log lines when
will this come up
well i think there are a few different
situations um
you know in the classes that i teach we
usually start with log lines as sort of
the first iteration of your story so
just like you and i were talking about
trying to figure out what's that what's
the story that you actually want to
write um we use log lines as a way to
kind of figure that out like what is
this story that you're trying to tell
um in that case i think that you know
it's we put much more of the focus on
getting those essentials of the story
into the log line so that it's
um we can tell if that foundation is
solid before we start
developing the story further but you
might also use a log line in a query
letter
or to pitch to somebody in person um you
know that
that elevator pitch of your story so if
you're using that version of a log line
you're probably going to think a little
bit more carefully about the language
that you use
because it's not just for internal use
anymore you're actually presenting this
as
you know this is the product essentially
that i'm trying to pitch you so you'll
probably be a little bit more careful
about word choice and
a little bit more conscious of getting
really conveying the tone of the story
and sort of
that that feel of the movie if you can
through the word choice and through
um just the language and the way you're
describing the situation
i'm sorry can you explain foundation i
know that's jumping a little bit uh oh
yeah off topic but
no the um when i talk about the
foundation that's just me referring to
kind of those
essential building blocks of your story
so the the protagonist
the story goal the antagonist or
opposition
and the stakes like those are the things
that every story needs you kind of have
to have those elements and so
that's where i start if i'm helping
someone figure out
what you know what story they're telling
or figure out what's not working about
their story
you just have to start with the
foundation layer and then and then work
your way up right so
make sure that that's solid and then we
can talk about the other pieces that go
into making your story work
so what if someone says well i don't
have a really strong antagonist but i
have a great sidekick character
is it because there's no opposition
there's nothing that this hero needs to
overcome
yeah that could be that would be my
first instinct is if someone says
they're writing a story that doesn't
have an antagonist
um i would it wouldn't be necessarily a
you know a deal breaker but i would want
to know where is that conflict coming
from right because
if you are telling a story where sort of
nothing goes wrong it's probably going
to
be either a pretty short story or we're
just going to get bored pretty quickly
so i would want to know i would question
where is that conflict coming from if
it's not
if it's not a sort of you know
traditional like direct
conflict that we can see between two
people or a person in a group or you
know that type of thing
then then what is making this um
journey for your protagonist so
difficult and
or so interesting you know